all right so spooky spooky what
neighborhood did you grow up in I grew
up with the city of La born and raised
on uh I am an active gang member at the
age of 12 years old gang called Westside
orphans 9th Street Marlo that's why side
crossing over Figueroa by Westlake monta
Park closer over figure Roma is gangs on
this side open wholesale stores 80
Street crazy ladders Muslim Russia
Whitmer Rockwood easy right as orphans
I'm in there president when it's 21 I
came out when I was 35 first one was
attempted robbery that when it came in
and the judge Tom could you point out
they didn't try to kill you
yes your honor if right there son of a
gun
seven years with a strike let's go out
of seven years you figure you know you
learned something I mean John Doe
letters and all this you know I'm not
changing I have a dream only have four
days and got set in to be robbery with a
knife the PD want to give you 21 years
21 years for what I think we've you know
I went to a dope house that's sold crack
cocaine to kids I bought it Alan said he
didn't wanna sell it to me I can't even
do any money on the table I mean you
know now first I give in my name is a
plate right there vault on the dope but
I mean good business here's the money
didn't want sell it to me Mike boom [ __ ]
that I mean cops came in everyone's on
the ground he say he's a snitch right
I'll see you in County he bailed out
[ __ ] I wanted cordis CCB
he showed up in a purple uniform what
the [ __ ] sweaty the [ __ ] he says
yes your honor
should I kill me mmm fireman PD nah I
want poor pert I want proper you know
you and Darren out again it gets me but
I
no I know except so I open the blue book
of off our our rights and our what we
could get out of jail free and uh read
that blue book and wrote my codes and
defend myself for a proper 21 years I
went before the judge and said Your
Honor I'm here before you again in your
same courtroom when you offer me seven
years and I guess I didn't know my
mistake III am not perfect but Your
Honor I guess I learned my lesson
I didn't kill the man Your Honor you
just point the finger at me Your Honor
do the crime do the time what can you
give me right now your honor
well let's see here uh this my knife all
right okay I can you let me strike let's
go
your lemon is right got done with seven
years out four days you Night Live in
years paroled April 23rd 2014 I've been
on ever since that high life criminal to
level three to level four the whole the
shoot program for 180 put me at the last
end with the big boys breaking out the
rules you're gonna know my life I heard
what respect is and what they wish they
have one chance to be in your shoes to
get a [ __ ] release date will be more
than anything for them because they
share their knowledge of wisdom to you
while they're in there freezing life
you're gonna learn and I learned I got
my GED in prison
I took [ __ ] a course first I called
you for four and a half years read every
paid for books wait
fine I got a better girl I better learn
something about a four and a half years
got me a mastery in psychology rest my
case
it's now much to do with how you do it
now you speak and how you talk is that
amongst yourself but in this dog game
I'll work with fillies there that's my
boy and all there's another and they rob
you dry when you're asleep
hmm I just do me only a handful of two
or three that I give him hard to know no
man or woman I'm not trying to fake no
funk however my demeanor looks another
Ice Show in front of you guys I guess I
stand out I guess I know why touching I
figure that out Daniel when he's sober
spooky what he's a gangster and question
mark still working on him respect me and
respect others Jones also done to you
don't [ __ ] my money to [ __ ] my dope I
won't [ __ ] with you just with my fam BAM
my family pay the price you know I mean
you know common sense pays awful if
you're not common sense enough they say
no YMCA I'm not here to take care of you
I'm here just do me and then get busted
with you now we got a problem
Joyce was my father was a heroin addict
you know when I was 12 years old
you know heroin when I first met her
toys at 12 years old 12 13 14 15 and 17
od'd in the hotel a steward and there at
once been to the hospital in the home
was wrong parole woke up in a tub guys I
thought I was chingon three moles Cove
applause drawing look at the window on
his phone spooky at the coke can and
everything him charges little thing like
yeah he's stupid
don't worry about me what about you
but I'm trying to be something I'm not
because I'm trying to grow up in the
fast lane I guess as a kid doing heroin
was some good [ __ ] back then and you did
too much you auto homies had to throw
the [ __ ] tub to Vic and safety to
save your ass and they don't get busted
[Music]
five oldies dealer nothing gets worse
teenagers 17 high school lemon drop
salmon drop can you see it ah make some
heroin is wrong with you huh don't mind
me huh
mama gets worse never gets better
childhood my father was a drug addict he
slammed in front of me transactions in
the house like it was a fine thing to do
kill real good gear okay we are no
you're not good I hope I hope you know I
mean I'm not my son not my son I was the
only child parents the four to six years
old new stepfather came in ball had no
kids my mom been working the banking
business for almost 24 years right here
on hope and flowers City National Bank
my mom raised me as a gentleman always
say yes please always say no thank you
always say bless you always excuse me
nervously yeah okay no never never say
always be polite I think my mom for that
my dad over the years encountered that
you know what he did was wrong and he
always try to make amends never mad at
him just how he treated my mom
stepfather came in abused me slap me
oh then huh hold the day Mike okay cool
whatever he bought me a bike a dino
crisis
oh cool same day he [ __ ] bought it
for me able to find a store to give me a
soda and some chips and they [ __ ]
stole the bike when I went in and out
how [ __ ] crazy is this I just got
this [ __ ] bike and he stole it from
me
i mock him off from work I'm you know
mom have a problem with John bike that
he bought from me they stoled it
what do you mean well I went to the
store oh my god yeah yeah when he comes
home you know I'm scared man I didn't
you know do our purpose he came home I
was so scared when the backyard played
basketball first thing he said where's
your bike it's a John I went to the
store you know what I made you something
today you lie in the room and made a
[ __ ] wood him down what's that
which hasn't been no
my father for about two three minutes
damn [ __ ] 12 13 years old fighting
Antron I pinned me down
he finally pay me down and smack me and
smacked me and smack me and smacks and
smack me so many times I lost count I
know my mass was no come on talk to my
dad's for weekend
my dad was busy something get ready take
a shower mill yeah Patel stuff [ __ ] is
that your ass what is that on your ass I
was spared that's my dad's you my dad
y'all him you know oh no my dad wanna
kill his ass
I've been abused by my stepfather until
he had a kid of his own my step-brother
whatever he's just like it's dead
I learned fast lane I'd run away at 12
years old and I've been living it says
Todd resolved I'm 40 now decade and a
half of prison life and six years of my
freedom I'm still blooming I'm still
developing but I ain't going back it's
not what he does how you do it I do
heroin some more crack ice that crystal
smoke crystal
smoke we live in pineapple hey cool I'm
the most coolest person I come by I get
greens hi spooky hey what's up okay
that's me that's me get respect and I
know how to never change I how about
thought let me help but I know this game
is just for told you cannot make excuses
on [ __ ] when I already know your
[ __ ] just be real about it if they can't
I'm not working with feelings I get [ __ ]
how my Leah's how desperate you are
I don't you don't care for me /
therefore you just be real it's a dirty
game something I do it
I have eight kids or girls and four boys
yes my almost 19 years old her name is
Daniela Rita Michele Morales how's the
first one I want is a girl we had a
better baby boy in the beginning but she
had 18 chromosomes
she was gained high or methamphetamine
baby died inside Marie labor open hey my
baby boy mr. was head to my hand
it's like it was designed like this Wow
my first song that my dad's name Dinah
Morales I'm Daniel Michael braless jr.
that'll been down at the throat I got me
a girl my mom's name is Rita my mom
always wanted a girl she had two boys
I'm my middle name is Michael I flipped
it to Michelle my monster first round
daughter it's for you mom Danielle wait
a Michelle Morales thank you young yeah
I don't have my kids with me they're all
you know what their love with my aunties
and uncles my grandpa's
but they know about the father they know
I've been in the beginning when I was
work at the time diapers clothing rent
yes
at the same time you know me doing what
I did do that time it pauses everything
is gonna pop now do you care them do you
care how we live
yes not
I live to learn to tell that cannot hold
my past from on mistakes as I live today
in the future
what I did in the past is my past I
clean it you know I mean no more no more
I mean I live today I live the past live
the present but from the future asked me
a question I tell the licensure sitting
free I'm not going back to prison on
that yacht was that what they kill
people on a daily basis I am NOT getting
killed eating breakfast put your apples
in table you get killed bumping into
someone you get killed
interrupting some conversation you get
killed it's not respect
how does speak me spoken to know when
you speak you speak correctly hey dude
April high-level respect I rather live
on a soldier in dead like a coward
I was waived by the best and I thank God
I survived because your am before you
telling me my lifestyle was the Big O oh
yeah there's beginners as advances
expert
what are you see yourself at man I'm
over here the expert [ __ ] man [ __ ] you
know what is your what is your what is
he yourself at me master - [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's mine
all this [ __ ] for every little mistake
you cry for although the elders thought
I was on with the problems I'm only 40th
Lee I'm 21 [ __ ] I don't let this misery
make me feel like I'm in the mess with
you guys miss rivers help me [ __ ]
you sit there I'll be able to hear
Finding Nemo find me I'm gonna be at
finding dory no no Jimmy I made me look
bad make you something bad don't did you
put with a cover Tanya I'm very well
experienced I'm very well intelligent
it's because what I do that make me a
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] don't don't don't do
that don't do that you won't like you
won't like it when I'm angry I've been a
boxer for years it's a kid from 6 to 9
couldn't oppose a [ __ ] drug test
I'm nothing fetta me
ah from 10 to 13 10 to 13 4 years of
boxing got kicked out cuz of drug test
gladiator school went to prison show you
the [ __ ] pressure point so you had a
[ __ ] survive Slayer had a [ __ ] hit
people take a lot faster as I hit 21
before I went to prison I went to
Arizona for [ __ ] Navy SEALs pass the
[ __ ] test and it wasn't a goal for a
[ __ ] to be a Navy SEALs four months
of boot camp and cut it [ __ ] passing
a drug test cuz you got high on the
[ __ ] bootcamp
it was stupid [ __ ] nothing in life
you couldn't pass but yeah the bars the
mud they're [ __ ] the conditioning the
workout that was fun in life it almost
crying I loved it yeah
I live for the throw the moment I live
on the edge full force I got a death
destructors I got kicked off damn what I
forget my name and my signature I hereby
have them give my whole right hand so
tell us your thoughts just help me God
Navy SEALs honor respect means a lot to
them be real they mold you to be a
soldier not to be fake if I would have
made it what they'll pass that [ __ ]
drug test if I would have passed my
house a big hopper I've been Navy SEAL
Team six I speak from experience I know
what I'm doing I know I just I know
I have the these--oh and I have Jackie
too from one lady - from one lady
letici Ellsworth at a young age when I
went in the prison
she was from free better flaccid she
went to her neighborhood with a friend
and I Drive my went by and her friends
got killed in this in the car and a six
year old boy got shot my mother made the
best decision of her life and not tell
me I was in prison she did she got a
shot and she passed away when I came up
during my time hey mom well if this
young I'm sorry me oh she passed away
what should i crying is this serious I
don't say barium Rose Hills
two years later my homeboys show me a
girl named Jackie don't do drugs
workaholic has a nine-year-old son and
had a baby boy through me family [ __ ]
reunion she wanted me to go with her I
said no no been up for [ __ ] days I'm
tired I'm all I know yeah you're [ __ ]
auntie you uncle your cousins and all
that no I'm a dead man walking with no
please if you love I don't want her gone
I said no [ __ ] when I do you I hit her
at a red light on her side impact killed
her first son survived as I go to the
hospital
Dolf Lauren [ __ ] guys put him in there
abuelita burrito I stop no kid came es
una rata for me mama it's a procurement
our own any English that's the guy that
I want to give us a ride at someone's
dead I don't want to see you start a key
I don't want you to wake her turn around
walk away
I don't know what love is but loving not
to be like that
listening to love was in your life how
about now
free been doing [ __ ] time long time
I'm not in a hurry to get ready [ __ ]
because all this is game toriel here I
must have I'm gonna die in heat like I
want to get my little no I got more for
myself let me stay for myself it seems
to me that everyone loves me who's that
no no fake the fog be real knock it off
I got time for this Jerry Springer
Montel Williams start to feel [ __ ] you
mean play me plain yourself this dope
came in getting any better scheme worse
by the minute people think that's game
then that's the sad thing about it's not
game cuz game worse six place matter
Imams give me the book be right back on
hold on Taveras is it's gonna be a bumpy
ride
in 2002 before I went to prison I had a
little production uh introduction about
me to tell people who I am to get my
husband to make a [ __ ] out one poem for
one sue one poem for one soup just give
me you know what your statement is and
how many kids you got or this is a
dating game or your girlfriend or
whatever your auntie you are whatever
the Navajo just nothing I wrote a
[ __ ] abduction for myself Know Who I
am
and the title is just say no an action
shows the show one day trip to one night
pick up the pencil start to write what's
one messy behind closed door let me see
a thing say no more
a time to open up a mindful what I know
put many words on paper i watch the show
time doesn't have to pray good things
come to those who wait I think back up
all the mistakes [ __ ] how much more am I
gonna take evil let's just back up watch
the show
come on Daniel do some more falling
drugs come my way pick them up and do
some more last no roll which no one
knows one less man without a soul it's
put this away may I stop saying it I
show some action today it's a long walk
to the end of the road there might be
many mistakes you've have to take take
it from me take this with you just say
no and watch the show your icy pain
people walk in the rain so we death he's
going insane it's like a place of evil
hell people waiting to be hanged you
tell me when is the time when are you
ready where's my had to say these drugs
not for me walk with me to a place you
would like to see his that my family
look let me not know who I be is this
death I've fallen upon me look down at
your feet Jenny people yelling and
crying because this disease is so sick
many people lots of brain nothing let
the land of pain you tell me why is it
time what are you ready Heavenly Father
guys I pray to you and has it knees
asking forgiveness please walking to my
family please need to be my son open
your eyes
just remember this walking journeys a
land of hell I'm here today share with
you about my addition live and tell
permit just for the day I think I'm okay
my experience in termite my life is
beyond [ __ ] painful